[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat
et cette semaine avec kathia gilder nous
recevons pour commenter l'actualité la
députée est là faucillon bonjour un jour
et c'est katia qui vous présente witam
est la faucille bonjour bonjour vous
êtes député communiste des
hauts-de-seine vous commencé à militer
en 2005 notamment contre le contrat
première embauche première élection en
conseillère municipale puis conseillère
départementale l'année d'après et 2007
2017 pardon marque votre entrée à
l'assemblée nationale nouveau visage à
36 ans parmi les 17 députés du groupe
communiste et républicain alors vous
êtes assez proche de clémentine autain
votre collègue de la france a soumise
avec qui vous avez rêvé d'une riposte au
parti majoritaire des manuels vaqueront
même d'un big bang de la gauche vous
l'avez écrit quitte à faire donc cause
commune avec le parti de jean luc
mélenchon au sco aujourd'hui ce rêve est
la faucille on est toujours d'actualité
la cause commune je crois que ça doit
être la cause commune dé gauche et de
l'écologie
on voit bien comment aujourd'hui face à
ce qui se prépare pour 2022 et à une
majorité qui organise non pas un face à
face avec l'extrême droite mais qui
vient préempter les thèses de l'extrême
droite
combien il y aurait besoin de faire
force de faire alternative sur des bases
de gauche clairement à gauche et
d'écologie et nous voyons combien elle
est aujourd'hui éparpillé salle yves
hocher et les logiques unique à gauche
pour vous ai compris avec le parti
socialiste je ne sais pas si ça passe
par un candidat unique parce que je ne
sais pas mme à la fois ci c'est possible
et si c'est complètement sous une table
parce que je le redis je crois qu'il
faut que ce soit sur des bases de
rupture des bases clairement ancré à
gauche qui font une articulation entre
le social et l'écologie et je dois dire
que j'ai un doute aujourd'hui si
l'ensemble des gauche et de l'écologie
sont en capacité de s'unir sur ses
basques les meubles en revanche à
insoumise en tout cas au moins déjà mais
d'abord vers jeu
je suis une militante et une élue
communiste qui a participé au front de
gauche avec le parti de gauche à
l'époque et avec ensemble où était jouée
clémentine autain mais aussi avec des
personnalités issues des lunes à gauche
et l'écologie
et je crois que le curseur en tout cas
se situe là un curseur ancré dans le
social et dans et dans l'écologie mais
qu' évidemment il y as besoin de
l'élargir si nous voulons gagner pour
transformer et on va voir ensemble les
titres de cette émission avec au
sommaire de parlement hebdo le vote
solennel sur le projet de loi pour
conforter le respect des principes de la
république
le texte a été adopté avec les seules
voix de la majorité
c'est l'amendement scandale de la
semaine senna le gouvernement veut
instaurer le vote par anticipation pour
la prochaine élection présidentielle
sur le fond comme sur la forme il a fait
l'unanimité contre lui
et puis un pas de plus pour renforcer la
protection des mineurs face aux
violences sexuelles l'assemblée a adopté
une proposition de loi qui criminalise
toute relation sexuelle entre un adulte
et un mineur de moins de 15 ans on
commence avec la fin de ce premier acte
à l'assemblée les députés qui ont adopté
le projet de loi qui conforte le respect
des principes de la république
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte a été voté en première lecture
après 135 heures de débat et un vote
solennel en séance publique à
l'assemblée qui a voté quoi et pourquoi
les explications des amendes à gabat la
majorité n'a pu compter que sur elle
même pour faire adopter le projet de loi
comportant les principes de la
république pour 347 contre 151 à
l'assemblée nationale adopté c'est une
loi qui permet de lutter contre les
communautarismes les séparatistes la
contestation de la règle commune
notamment par une partie des courants
les plus radicaux et intégriste de
l'islam
la droite elle s'est très largement
opposée au projet de loi 97 voix contre
5 abstentions
il ya beaucoup de manques beaucoup de
lacunes beaucoup d'angles morts la
question migrateurs la question de la
radicalisation dans nos écoles dans nos
prisons dans nos universités
il ya aussi beaucoup de faiblesses il
n'y a pas de délit de séparatisme dans
ce texte mais aussi des renoncements et
puis aussi un texte qui est liberticide
vote contre pour la totalité des
insoumis ce texte lui n'aura fabriqué
comme halo supplémentaire de suspicion
envers l'ensemble d'associations
généralement animé par nos concitoyens
de confession musulmane ainsi que pour
la moitié des communistes
l'autre moitié a préféré s'abstenir tout
comme les socialistes autres abstention
notable celle des députés du
rassemblement national le gouvernement
ne nomme pas ce contre quoi ils luttent
c'est-à-dire l'islamisme ils n'osent pas
ils taquinent l'islamisme sans se donner
les moyens de véritablement l'éradiquer
par conséquent nous ne pouvions pas le
soutenir
en revanche il ya tout un nombre de
petites disposition c'est tout petit pas
même s'ils sont minimum eh bien il faut
les prendre en compte le projet de loi
sera examiné à partir du 30 mars au
sénat
alors elle a faucillon les députés de
votre groupe communiste n'ont pas tous
voté de la même façon et vous avez voté
contre ce projet de loi est ce que pour
vous les principes de la république ne
sont pas en danger
je le disais au début de l'émission
nous sommes dans une séquence pour le
gouvernement je la situe avec trappe par
exemple ce qui s'est passé à trappes
avec la loi séparatisme qu'on principes
républicains et avec les accusations
d'islamophobie schisme à l'université
dans une séquence où le gouvernement
s'attache à venir valider les sujets et
les thèses de l'extrême droite il se
disait remparts en 2017
enfin au moment du sud au moment du
second tour aujourd'hui il entretient
une confusion permanente entre les
ternes de communautarisme d'islamisme
radical de terrorisme et ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas acceptable
d'abord parce que il fasse a fait du
maire du rs je termine avec eux c'est
d'abord sa taille du mal à des gens il
faut le dire comme ça et ensuite parce
que ça nous éloigne d'une bataille
efficace contre les obscurantismes et
contre le terrorisme n' était pas
nécessaire dans ce projet de loi il ya
assez peu de choses à la fin quand on y
regarde qui permettent de lutter
efficacement contre les obscurantismes
et je rappelle il ya un discours d'
emmanuel macron ça arrive de temps en
temps où il ya des termes que je peux
rejoindre et il dit que la république
elle n'est jamais achevée elle est
toujours à conquérir
il ya quand même beaucoup de choses à
conquérir dans la période quand on est
président de la république dans la
situation quand les enfants d'ouvriers
n'accepte toujours pas de manière
importante aux études supérieures
quand vous vivez en hlm et que votre
couleur de peau n'est pas blanc jean
sion et social fait 20 fois plus arrêter
quand vous êtes dans des quartiers
d'éducation prioritaire et que le
gouvernement retire des moyens voilà des
choses qu'il ya aujourd'hui à conquérir
pour notre vie république vous ne
reconnaissez tout de même pas des
qualités à ce texte rhône prenez par
exemple marie george buffet votre
collègue qui a choisi elle de s'abstenir
elle estime qu'il ya des avancées des
mesures pour défendre les femmes
victimes de polygamie des mesures sur le
mariage forcé des mesures sur le
contrôle financier des cultes ça voulait
de mettet sur la question polygamie
mariage forcé certificat de virginité
vous verrez d'ailleurs vous pourrez
ceux qui nous écoutent pourront regarder
mes votes et je crois qu'ils sont
suffisamment claires je suis opposé au
certificat de virginité comme tout le
monde je crois à peu près je suis opposé
à la polygamie d'ailleurs ce n'était pas
tout à fait l'interdiction de la
polygamie qui était présente dans le
texte que ça existe déjà sur les
mariages forcés nous avons fait des
propositions
je pense d'ailleurs que ces propositions
n'avaient rien à faire dans un texte
pour conforter les principes
républicains
rien à faire pour lutter contre lens
l'entrisme religieux radical nous avons
examiné il y à peu une loi sur les
violences sexistes et sexuelles
ces propositions avaient leur place à
cet endroit et d'ailleurs elle aurait
permis que nous discutions de plein
d'autres sujets comme par exemple la
chirurgie réparatrice de l'hymen c'est
un problème
elle n'est pas présente dans cette loi
mais parce que messieurs rastel les
bolides nous parce que le mythe de la
virginité n'a absolument pas à voir avec
la religion même si elle est évidemment
présente dans les principes religieux
elle a à voir avec la domination
patriarcale et donc vous voyez bien
qu'ici il ya une confusion qui se créent
comme si la question de la domination
patriarcale et est propre aux religions
et propre qu'à une seule religion la
religion musulmane c'est cette confusion
que je dénonce par mon par mon vote
contre qui je crois est assez bien
comprises par les citoyens du pays vous
ce texte y stigmatise clairement une
religion en particulier va regardons
quand même les déclarations qui ont
amené cette ce projet de loi mais pour
monsieur internet
jamais on ne part de l'histoire musicale
nommée angleterre un projet loi c'est un
texte qu'on examine et c'est aussi un
contexte et penser aujourd'hui que il ce
texte pour le gouvernement n'est pas un
objet politique n'est pas un fait
politique
c'est à mon avis être assez naïf est ce
que pour vous aujourd'hui le séparatisme
c'est une réalité il ya ce qui a
vraiment quand même ses problèmes qui
existent cette démarche qui consiste à
dire que les règles d'une religion sont
supérieures à celles de la république et
qu'il faut lutter contre je crois qu'il
ya des problèmes qui existent
effectivement et que l'obscurantisme et
d'ailleurs plusieurs formes
d'obscurantisme et je ne nie pas qu'elle
existe dans l'islam radical pose
problème dans le pays c'est une réalité
je pense d'ailleurs que les défaillances
de la république ils sont pour beaucoup
et donc c'est pour ça quand on dit
respect de principes républicains en
même temps que république généreuse ces
présents dans l'exposé des motifs
en quoi aujourd'hui la république et
généreuse
en quoi elle permet aujourd'hui aucun
volet social dans lord à la fois il
manque un volet social fort et à la fois
je crois que les mesures qui sont
énoncés sont extrêmement faibles
regardons par exemple quand il ya un
gouvernement qui va boire le thé avec
les les princes d'arabie saoudite quand
nous vendons des armes à l'egypte par
exemple ces questions là aujourd'hui
elles sont passées sous silence par le
gouvernement je crois qu elle fonce
beaucoup plus de mal à l'islamisme est
beaucoup plus de bien à l'islamisme
politique que les questions de
certificat de virginité même si je ne
sous estime pas la question des
certificat de virginité
je crois qu'on a là un texte
relativement fourre tout qui créait qui
continue de créer de la confusion et qui
passe trop sous silence les manquements
de la république pour de nombreux
citoyens de notre notre territoire
alors on va passer l afo sion à cet
amendement du gouvernement qui ne passe
pas au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet amendement c'est celui que le
gouvernement a déposé mardi matin pour
instaurer le vote par anticipation lors
de la prochaine élection présidentielle
certains sénateurs ont d'abord cru à une
blague à droite bruno retailleau a
dénoncé je le cite une magouille
politicienne quant à la gauche pourtant
favorable à une modernisation du scrutin
elle juge le dispositif très mal pensée
sandra cerqueira déposé au dernier
moment mardi rejeté à une large majorité
deux jours plus tard
sans surprise le sénat s'opposent
largement à l'amendement du gouvernement
ouvrant la voie au vote électronique
pour la présidentielle de 2000 22
cet amendement prévoit pour tout
électeur qui le souhaitent de voter sur
des machines pas forcément dans sa
commune d'origine
dans les six jours qui précèdent le
scrutin pour marlène schiappa l'objectif
est de faire baisser l'abstention est de
moderniser la démocratie que nous
travaillons pour moderniser le vote que
beaucoup d'appels ont été faits d'appel
du pied à la fois de la part d'élèves et
des députés mais également des sénateurs
sur les questions de modernisation du
vote
nous ne passons rien en force nous
proposons cet amendement est le mot de
la fin d'un évidemment il vous
appartient à droite et au centre on
continue de dénoncer une manoeuvre
politicienne
vous voulez les mains libres comme
d'habitude vous voulez tout réglé par
décret comme d'habitude vous arrivez
avec un texte qui est plein de lacunes
de failles qui n'a pas été étudiée
sérieusement
alors là je dis si c'est ça votre
modernité alors je suis obligé de vous
dire je préfère me ranger parmi les
anciens que parmi ces modernes là la
gauche pas opposée au départ au vote
anticipé dénonce non sans humour
l'impréparation du gouvernement et le
manque de concertation
je précise au gouvernement qui semble
découvrir en séparant des habits de la
modernité par une suggestion qu'il est
précurseur en la matière que cela fait
des mois neuf exactement
que nous ne comptons plus le nombre
d'amendements pour moderniser notre
droit électoral et arrive
l'amendement du gouvernement qui a un
avantage c'est de faire l'unanimité
contre lui
comment tu es une bonne idée potentiel
eh bien je vais vous donner une réponse
comme ça cet amendement sur le vote par
anticipation qui n'a pas été d'abord
déposé et adopté à l'assemblée ne pourra
pas être réintroduits devant les députés
après la commission mixte paritaire le
gouvernement on n'aura alors pas d'autre
choix que de proposer un nouveau texte
est la faucille on ya le fond il ya la
forme on va parler de la fin mais
d'abord le fond sur le fond à ce que la
pandémie cas obligé à reporter certaines
élections qui a partiellement mis la
démocratie sous cloche on peut le dire
ne justifie pas de moderniser même dans
l'urgence et bien les scrutins
aujourd'hui il ya très certainement
besoin aujourd'hui de revoir notre mode
de scrutin la façon de voter etc
mais d'abord il n'ya pas que la crise
sanitaire qui nous amène à ça il ya la
grande défiance démocratique une
démocratie représentative à bout de
souffle tout ça devrait évidemment nous
nous inviter à le fermer la voie qui est
choisie là franchement elle crée de
l'incompréhension je ne sais même pas si
les ministres sont en capacité
aujourd'hui de répondre sur le pourquoi
cet amendement aujourd'hui être moderne
amendement de dernière arrivée c'est pas
parce qu on appuie sur un bouton que
c'est plus moderne que parce qu'on prend
un papier
voyez la modernité il vous suffit là
j'ai juste voulu faire le gouvernement
avec cet amendement sur qualifiée de
surprise je vous avoue pas tellement
parce qu'aujourd'hui si vous ne pouvez
pas voter le jour du scrutin
il ya la procuration qui existe qui
fonctionne elle a elle même été
modernisées composition du double
procuration mais mondial s'allonge tout
ça est tout à fait possible évoluer
lutter contre l'abstention évidemment je
crois que c'est une ambition
que nous avons toutes et tous parfois
pour des raisons différentes parfois
pour des pour des raisons communes moi
je suis attaché à regarder
d'extraordinaire abstention des classes
populaires
elle nous inquiète elle nous préoccupe
parce que les classes populaires sont
sont celles qui sont le plus touchés par
par les politiques publiques
c'est celle qui en trinquent le plus et
c'est celle qui sont le plus absente
aussi souvent de tous les lieux tous les
espaces politiques de décisions et
délibérations
sauf que je ne crois pas que le fait de
lutter contre cette abstention puisse
passer par le fed allait appuyer sur un
bouton une semaine avant il ya certains
joueurs qui le pense parce que regarder
ya eu cette tribune de 38 maire député
dans le monde qui ont défendu la machine
à voter ils considèrent que c'est une
machine de guerre qu'il faut utiliser en
tant de coville dont il ya quand même
peut-être un vrai débat sur le fond est
coté dans ces machines qu'il faut
peut-être modernisée dans ma
circonscription les deux existent à à
columbia déjà les machines à voter de sa
vie ni certain nombre de temps
aujourd'hui à gennevilliers à villeneuve
il n'y a pas ce que je constate c'est
que ça n'a pas changé
le vote ni l'abstention ce que je
constate c'est qu'une ville comme
villeneuve qui a plus de classes
populaires que colomb continuent de
s'abstenir et que l'abstention continue
de monter particulièrement chez les
classes populaires c'est pas la machine
à voter le problème c'est aujourd'hui
quelle confiance quel engagement quelles
politiques publiques sont menées pour
pas simplement donner confiance mais que
les classes populaires ce centre engagé
dans ces élections et qu'elle pense que
elles vont y gagner dans les
transformations qui vont être produites
le patron de la droite au sénat a vu
dans cet amendement une magouille
politique est censé favoriser peut-être
le double vote et notamment qui
favoriserait ceux qui ont voté en masse
pour emmanuel macron c'est à dire les
grandes métropoles
est ce que il a raison alors je sais pas
s'il a raison ce que je sais c'est que
dans la période où la défiance est forte
et où on a vu aux états unis ce que le
vote par anticipation pouvait créer
comme confusion à l'issue du vote et par
là je ne remet évidemment pas en cause
l'élection de joe biden je dis
simplement que ça a créé de forts doutes
et beaucoup de confusion à l'issue du
vote dans une période comme nous vivons
en ce moment dans le pays
on voit ce qui se dit sur les vaccins on
voit ce qui se dit sur tout un tas de
choses de ce type
je ne suis pas sûr que la première
mesure pour gagner de la confiance soit
effectivement de créer du trouble avec
une machine à voter une semaine avant
est-ce que sur le fond j'ai aussi
l'impression que le gouvernement par ce
type d'amendements permet que pendant 10
minutes ici peut-être au lieu de parler
du rsa pour les jeunes
au lieu de parler tout un tas de mesures
qui seraient extrêmement utiles à la
population permet que voilà un peu une
manoeuvre discussions pour nous
discutions pendant 10 minutes aux
quelque chose qui n'arrivera pas mais
est ce que dans cette manoeuvre de
diversion vous ne trouvez pas qu'il
s'est un peu tiré une balle dans le pied
il a été tellement cavaliers finalement
il a fait l'unanimité contre lui alors
que bon par exemple au sénat y avait
beaucoup de sénateurs qui avaient
travaillé sur le sujet et qui proposait
un certain nombre de dispositifs
alternatifs comme j'ai eu à réaliser je
suis pas certaine que le gouvernement
avait véritablement envie que ça
aboutisse peut être un ballon d'essai à
londres c'était voilà pour voir ce que
ça a donné
les pieds aussi pour nous faire parler
voilà d'autres choses et ben voilà
allez on va
et avec le troisième thème de cette
émission avec l'adoption à l'unanimité
d'une proposition de loi portée par la
députée isabelle santiago
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte d'isabelle santiago est donc
une initiative socialiste il criminalise
les relations sexuelles entre un adulte
et un mineur de moins de 15 ans la
proposition de loi a été soutenue et
réécrite aussi par la majorité
explications et compte-rendus de séance
avec stéphanie des pierres les niches
parlementaires ne se passe jamais comme
prévu pour la majorité à l'acteur il y à
une proposition de loi socialiste pour
mieux protéger les mineurs face aux
violences sexuelles
h2 non consentement à 15 ans
renforcement des peines délit spécifique
d'inceste le ps et la république en
marche sont d'accord sur le principe dix
points sur les détails
acte 2 en commission le texte est
entièrement réécrit par la majorité
de quoi agacer la députée socialiste à
l'initiative de ces changements
c'est une situation ubuesque
je ne peux croire que le gouvernement
cautionne la méthode du coucou sur le
travail des parlementaires de
l'opposition
coup de théâtre cet après midi au milieu
de la discussion dans l'hémicycle les
socialistes obtiennent le soutien du
modem et d'agir pourtant alliée de la
république en marche acte 3 la version
des socialistes et donc restaurer un
possible vis-à-vis de l'opinion de
bloquer ce texte les députés la
république en marche vote donc cette
première mouture de la loi qui ne
convient ni au groupe ni au gouvernement
mais il y aura un acte iv une
proposition de loi sur le même sujet
déjà voté au sénat arrivera à
l'assemblée le 8 mars une nouvelle
occasion pour la majorité de faire
passer sa version alors le texte acte la
création d'un crime sexuel sur les
mineurs ce qui n'existe pas actuellement
dans le droit parce qu'on parle
d'atteinte sexuelle uniquement est ce
que pour vous vous dites il était temps
le législateur a mis du temps à ouvrir
les yeux sur écoute et aujourd'hui ce
matin c'est plutôt la satisfaction qui
m'anime
de voir enfin que toutes celles qui se
battent depuis des années pour que nous
en arrivions là la satisfaction de voir
que c'est aussi le mouvement mis tous
qui nous permet d'en arriver là
aujourd'hui une 1e unanimité sur ces
sujets aujourd'hui reste du sénat au
delà s'il fallait il faut que le droit
soit bouleversée il fallait que la loi
suivent les demandes de la sauce il ya
il ya un boulevard vers sa vie à un
bouleversement majeur qui se déroule
depuis quelques années sous nos yeux
dans la société
une expression nouvelle l'envi de
rapports nouveaux aussi entre hommes et
femmes l'envi aussi que les victimes
puissent être réellement entendu et
accompagner il ya des propositions cette
danse dans cette proposition de loi qui
date depuis trente ans quarante ans que
des associations de victimes revendique
depuis des années est de voir
aujourd'hui que et bien enfin enfin y
est sur la table par écrit des députés
des des sénateurs et des sénatrices qui
porte enfin par des textes de loi ceci
oui il ya de la satisfaction encore
faut-il ensuite des moyens pour que et
pour que ce soit effective ce que je
ferai à quel point après la
criminalisation du viol
combien aujourd'hui de voir à quel point
les violeurs continue de s'en sortir
et bien évidemment je sais que nous ne
sommes pas au bout du chemin
mais c'est des victoires arrachées sur
lesquels nous appuyer en attendant
espérait il est forcément tardif mais en
tout cas aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
évidemment une forme de soulagement de
voir que nous finissons par y arriver
vous ne vous dites pas qu'on est en
train aussi de légiférer dans l'émotion
parce que tout de même l'exécutif a
trouvés soudainement qu'il était urgent
est bien de faire face à ce sujet face à
l'opinion publique a été interpellé par
les livres de camille kouchner de
vanessa spring aura ce n'était pas
forcément le cas auparavant on a vu
aussi a prises de paroles assez
théâtrale d'emmanuel mcnicoll et
heureusement qu'il dit il sans
interpeller heureusement qu'il se sent
interpellé je le redis il ya des
propositions ici le crime spécifique
d'inceste
la criminalisation avec le seuil de 15
ans tout ça c'est des mesures demandées
depuis des années depuis des années et
dans lorsque nous avons examiné la loi
sur les violences sexistes et sexuelles
nous avons également porté la
criminalisation avec le seuil de 15 et
le de musiciens comment ça change a
juste dans l'émotion parce que l'émotion
elle est évidemment présente quand on
voit combien le procès pour pour julie
violée par par 20 des pompiers
aujourd'hui peine à passer aux assises à
avoir un viol caractérisée quand on voit
en 2010 est cette jeune cette jeune
femme qui aujourd'hui à 20 ans qui en
avaient 11 est acquis sur laquelle on
vient douter du consentement justement à
l'épaule était nécessaire on est bien il
égrène totalement nécessaire de
légiférer
eric dupond-moretti par exemple
lorsqu'il était devant le sénat lors de
l'examen la proposition de loi n'était
pas forcément favorable aux propositions
du sénat pour créer ce crime spécifique
et puis que de trois mois après et bien
tout est en train de changer
mais les lois de l'état loin c'est
toujours ça c'est la société qui permet
que les lois arrivé et est soit votée et
donc si eric dupond-moretti change
d'avis et qu'il change d'avis pour
permettre que les victimes soient mieux
entendu parce que c'est ce qui s'exprime
aujourd'hui dans la société et que c'est
possible et bien qu'ils le fassent et
encore en recettes sa responsabilité je
crois de le faire et et honnêtement je
crois que l'émotion elle l est pas elle
n'est pas grave quand on doit prendre
des décisions c'est pas celle qui doit
uniquement nous guider nous avons
toujours cette main qui tremble quand
nous avons à légiférer et donc il faut
il y a toujours un équilibre entre cette
émotion et cette raison alors mais
regardons que les propositions qui
finalement elles sont extrêmement
ancienne et qu'elle ne sorte
il ya deux mois jamais aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup quand même y en a une au sénat
que le gouvernement devrait reprendre
pour vraiment faire voter sa réforme il
ya celle d abel santiago voté hier vous
n'avez pas l'impression qu'il y en a un
peu trop qu'on n'aurait pas pu faire
il y en a ce score de 2-1 mais sans cela
c'est de la responsabilité du
gouvernement ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est parce que ce mouvement me to a
permis de faire entendre des
revendications extrêmement ancienne et
de juger qu'il était possible
aujourd'hui de faire de faire ce
bouleversement dans la loi que des
députés des sénateurs et des sénatrices
on mise sur la table des propositions de
loi aujourd'hui le gouvernement a trop
tardé et donc il est de sa
responsabilité que ces propositions de
loi
maintenant se transforment en actes
radin dans la société et très rapidement
merci merci beaucoup à la pression
d'avoir été l'invité de ce numéro de
parlement hebdo et on se retrouve comme
dans deux semaines très beau site de
programmes à tous cha cha
[Musique]